okay guys how's it going it's Justine
and today we're gonna be talking about
my top five favorite features in the new
iPhone 10 now my first feature that is a
favorite obviously there's probably more
than five but we're gonna just keep this
to the top things that I'm super into
number one the OLED screen and the first
thing that kind of took me by surprise
is how small this phone is now the phone
itself is small in comparison to any of
the plus sized phones but the crazy part
is is the actual screen itself is
slightly larger than the screen on the
plus phones so for size reference here
is the eight plus and here is the 10 so
judging by just the body size you can
tell that this one is much much smaller
than the plus but it's crazy to me
though is this is the iPhone 8 these are
almost the same exact size but when you
put the screen side-by-side that's where
you can see the huge difference between
the size of the screen and the eight
screen just take a look at that it
really is all screen I'm so proud of
myself because I haven't called the ex
one single time since I started this
video so Apple is calling this the super
Retina display one of the things that I
think a lot of people were worried about
is because there is this notch cut out
that is going to take away from watching
movies or watching content on your phone
and to be honest with you I really
didn't even notice that it was there you
have two options you can either enlarge
it to full screen so yes the notch will
be cut out or you can squeeze it and
shrink it down so that it only plays in
this little area right here since I
haven't had this very long I haven't
really got to watch any long feature
films or anything really that crazy
because I basically just got it and I've
been making videos non-stop I'll be
doing a full review once I've had this
for at least a week so stay tuned for
the week with iPhone 10 video thank you
Mike you guys know I gotta do one number
two is the front-facing portrait mode
and I absolutely love portrait mode on
the iPhone I've been using it ever since
it was first released into beta that I
was pretty surprised how well this
actually worked but with the new
front-facing features it's able to sense
depth and with that you're able to get
some incredible portrait mode photos
here's the field that I took while we
were outside and as you can see here
this is with portrait mode on and this
is with portrait mode off and also just
like the rear camera portrait mode you
can also go through and use some of the
portrait lighting
so let's take this photo for example
this is a picture that my sister took so
if we go into edit you'll see here you
have all of the same features that you
have from the back camera non portrait
mode for trip mode you can switch to the
natural light to the studio light
contour light and the stage lights which
didn't work very well on this photo but
I do have another one that it worked
really well on and I was quite impressed
look at that I mean that cut out almost
absolutely perfect
again the portrait mode is still in beta
so you will sometimes get an imperfect
photo and that doesn't just happen on
the iPhone that happens on any of these
phones that have these new portrait mode
effects I'll be doing a full comparison
video with the pixel to the no dates and
the new iPhone 10 so we'll be able to
get those shots and really see which one
is the best and again the hard part with
doing those types of comparison photos
some of the cameras perform better in
various Lighting's so it's really hard
to tell which is the best I still say
that whatever camera you have with you
that will always be the best one and
cleeshay I know but it's true
number three is wireless charging and I
know what all of you Android fan boys
and girls are saying we've had that
forever yeah okay I get it
but the pixel - what happened there
where's your wireless charging at I was
actually very surprised that they
decided not to do that but anyway moving
on the iPhone 10 and the iPhone 8 both
have wireless charging so if you always
already have a wireless charger as long
as it is Qi wireless enabled you'll be
able to charge your iPhone 10 or your
iPhone 8 so if you see all of those
little wireless charging stations around
at the mall or coffee shops there's a
really good chance that you will now be
able to utilize that with your iPhone
test there's two different chargers that
Apple has out there's this Belkin one
and there's this Mophie one the Falcon
one is significantly lighter but the
Mophie one is significantly smaller so
really I think it's kind of just a
preference on which one you think looks
better I think that I prefer the Mophie
one I have one at my desk and I also
have one in my bedroom where's this one
I feel like matches this desk very
nicely so I think it really just depends
on what you're looking for I would
suggest going the Apple Store and
checking them out but I also think I
probably would recommend the Mophie one
so you just take my recommendation if
you'd like
you
[Music]
number four is an emojis and this was a
huge highlight at the Apple event when
they first announced this I know it
seems a little silly and it seems a
little crazy but really this is just
showing off the facial recognition
technology that Apple has now in the
iPhone 10 I mean it's kind of weird to
just watch this group emoji mimic my
facial expressions like I close my eyes
I raise my eyebrows and it picks up all
of that Wow Wow wait wow-whee so this
type of detail that you're seeing now
this is only a small taste of what will
happen when Apple opens this up to other
developers what will they create I'm not
sure but I'm excited to find out I feel
like there's so many different
possibilities with a our kit and all of
the really cool augmented reality apps
haven't really messed around with that
if you guys have any favorite augmented
reality apps that you guys are trying or
checking out feel free to leave those in
the comments below and I would love to
check them out as well last but not
least and it's a very very huge
important part of iPhone 10 so
technically I probably saved the best
for last and that is face ID so setting
up face ID is very very simple all you
have to do is align your face after you
click get started so it tells you
exactly what you have to do position
your face looks like I need to move the
phone a little bit lower and now you
just move your head like so and then
you're gonna do it again just like that
and that's it your face scan is complete
and one of the things that I was really
shocked about is how fast this really is
and it is super intuitive and it seems
weird to sort of explain it to somebody
especially if they've never used any
type of facial recognition software I
use it in my surface studio I've used it
on my note 8 I've used it to my Samsung
s8 even though I've used it so many
times before in various different things
it still was so exciting to be holding
an iOS device and to just unlock with my
face and not only can you unlock your
phone with your face but you can pay
with your face basically any place that
you would be using touch ID face ID has
now replaced that you can use touch ID
to buy things but now you can use your
face to buy things I went to Whole Foods
and I use it for the first time and
it's really really exciting dependently
getting a pumpkin geez this is
a pumpkin cheese this is something that
I've never seen before but today is the
day just something they're into because
I've been to it
risa filming ok I just I just use Apple
pay with my face for the phrase the
first time I don't know why this is so
exciting what it is so when you guys use
this for the first time just let me know
what you think so those are my top 5
favorite things there's so many other
things that I really love about this
film but I will save those for my full
review video after I've actually got a
chance to play with this
I didn't even add that the camera is
amazing that clearly should be in the
top 5 feature oh there's just too many
things but so far I'm absolutely loving
this phone and I look forward to making
some more fun videos for you guys guys
have any suggestions on anything else
you would like to see me test out with
the new iPhone 10 leave those in the
comments below and I will see you guys
in my next video and if you're not
already subscribed make sure you hit
that subscribe button and that's it I'm
gonna go at it now so I'll see you later
[Music]